there used to be a time when the goal
was get a TV show get on a TV show and
then get into movies like everyone was
just trying to do this there was this
trajectory and I'm thinking especially
when you were on Seinfeld it's probably
like okay I was on SNL now I'm on
Seinfeld yeah then I gotta get into
movies and then I become a movie star
because that has to be the trajectory
and what we see now is yeah
no one cares they just care about good
work you can make a podcast and you know
what I mean and you can and you can
reach it's a completely different it's
like taking off one uh high-powered lens
and putting on a different lens that
takes a completely different kind of
picture it's still you but it's you in
all these different ways which I think
is kind of yeah very nice we're very
lucky to be alive we're very lucky
because you can sort of ping around and
do different uh
tackle different creative projects in a
way that perhaps wouldn't have been uh
accessible I don't know 20 years ago or
something like that used to be that in
your position they would have said like
okay you were on Seinfeld so now you
have to go do that again and you gotta
wait around till we find the right part
where you're someone's friend who comes
in and and chats in the apartment but
this way you can completely flip the
narrative yeah I don't know that's just
the thing that endlessly fascinates me
is I think about uh it's just these
technological changes but careers used
to be I think much more
restrained like people people were
confined to one kind of box right
exactly and now I think there's all the
fences are down everyone's wandering
into everything else and yeah I was
talking to some actor recently and
he's done so much great TV work and he's
also done some movie work but he was
sort of saying yeah but I need to get
back to movies and I said why no one
knows the difference anymore great work
on television or great work in the
movies it's just great work yeah what
was his answer
he agreed with me oh you convinced him
yeah yeah I convinced him we're talking
about Brad Pitt I was going to say I
thought it was Brad Pitt yeah Brad Pitt
was really down on you know not having
really a movie career and
um we hang out a lot you know and he's
done some TV stuff he was on friends
yeah and uh one appearance and I so I
talked him out of it he was really high
and he had forgotten that he had had a
movie career so I know what you mean
about the television to to movie thing
and back when I was doing Seinfeld
that's when I had both of my kids you
know so the idea and we were making 22
Episodes remember those days when it was
22 Episodes a season or 24 or whatever
so the idea of going off during the
Hiatus and and making movies was just no
bueno for me I couldn't bear the idea of
it and the irony of all of this is that
like in the last
a year and a half I've made it a ton of
movies yeah it's so weird and you're in
the Marvel Universe now I know I am
that's not tell me about that because
let me tell you something once you're in
that club forget about it I I don't know
if that's the case but I'm I'm really
doing this to impress my kids
and I'm not you I really am I
mean they wanted
you know they both would say mom come on
why why can't you be in whatever the
hell it is and I and I said yeah
so I met with these guys and I said you
know I could be I mean I could do
something you know I could punch
somebody and you know fly around or
whatever anyway cut two that was all it
took that's all it took and then why
don't by the way that was my pitch that
was the actual pitch I made okay well
guess what uh I think I could punch
somebody and fly around a little bit uh
maybe take a Punch Yeah
I could be punched yeah and people could
fly over me but but I don't see why I
can't be part it's DC but Plastic Man
feels like you
watch your reps to get a a meeting for
you with Kevin feige and all those
people and yeah kiss yourself yes I'm
going to well this is my pitch right now
I don't get out a lot so I'm just gonna
send them this segment of the podcast
but Kevin feige and the Marvel gang uh I
come on you know I've got a fan base uh
why are you making noises I don't know I
think maybe you'd be like an extra is
that mean to say yeah mine but I think
it's not nice to say I'm sorry but I
think that a distracting extra yeah hey
who's that handsome drink of water in
the background he could be like a snarky
uh what yeah what yes yeah that's my my
superpower is snark first of all you're
not gonna have a superpower yes thank
you thank you that's what I was trying
to say you're not gonna be one of the
heroes okay so I'll be the I'll be a guy
who is uh I'm working I'm cooking the
books in the background uh
might be like a corporate snarky guy
that I could see that's true
tastic yeah maybe I'm not sending this
to Marvel
it's too late you're cast uh but but I
mean so your kids now my kids my grown
men children right your 45 year old
children yeah seriously no they uh but
now they must want to come to the set
because they want to see like oh you
know you're shooting Falcon in the
Winter Soldier I want to be there I want
to I want to meet Falcon I want to see
all this cool stuff they're actually
they haven't asked me to come to the set
maybe they'll come I'm going down I'm go
I'm going to be shooting starting in
June for many months so I suspect that
they may want to come then and there's
going to be lots of fancy people in it
and so they'll get to meet if they come
they would get to meet cool folks I
don't know we'll see maybe they'll come
I have to say my kids never ask to meet
people how old are your kids now uh my
daughter is 19 and my son's 17. wow okay
but they're very and and they're they're
very polite they're really uh but
they've never bothered me they've never
bothered to meet anyone and then every
now and then they when they do really
want to meet someone I don't have the
clout to make it happen right so like
you know yeah my daughter would flip if
I could say Hey you know uh Taylor Swift
do you want to meet her and that's not
happening Taylor Swift's team has told
me no I haven't even approached but
she's just but you're pretty sure you're
gonna get a pass I'm pretty sure that uh
that I'm not even gonna try yeah so uh
I'm I'm not gonna try okay well fine I
can't help you
if I think you could no I can't yes you
could you have more clout than I have
you could call uh Taylor Swift's people
and say uh look Conan's kids want to
meet her well Conan wants to meet her
with one of his kids that's what this is
uh yeah yeah but I want to go in first
yeah you have a daughter and have like a
lunch and then my daughter can come in
at the end yeah why don't you fabricate
a pitch why I mean you've got this
company now so why don't you come up
with a story idea or something you were
pitching her that's it that's how you're
going to do it that's how I do it yeah
and you say you need to pitch to her
just like over lunch and then you have
your kids come by right okay we figured
it out this is perfect now we got to
figure out the pitch
you play
flailer snitch
that's your Marvel name yeah exactly
yeah uh I don't have a good pitch for
her